Speaker 1: Should we be surprised that within
hours of learning about the monkeypox outbreak
that is being investigated, the usual suspects
are already promulgating and promoting conspiracy
theories. No, we should not be surprised when
all you have is a. Hammer the hammer of we're
going to tell you who's really doing this, like
the globalist, globalist, internationalist,
Trotskyite socialist. Unlike Obama, Trudeau,
Macron. Yeah, exactly. It should not surprise
us that Marjorie Taylor GREENE and Alex Jones
and others are already ramping up with the
conspiracy theories. Marjorie Taylor GREENE is
focusing in on Bill Gates. Bill Gates and his
remember early in COVID. The idea was, well, Bill
Gates, through what looks like just philanthropy,
is trying to donate to vaccine
development to surreptitiously
track people's location through vaccine
microchips or whatever. Okay. Here is Marjorie
Taylor GREENE on Bill Gates and smallpox.
Speaker 2: Gates, why is Bill Gates running
everything? Why does he get to decide that? You
know, Bill Gates, I want to remind everyone,
he wants to grow fake meat in a petri dish and he
wants a peach tree. What says to drink poop water.
So I don't know why we're letting Bill
Gates decide our health decisions.
Speaker 1: I didn't think we were.
Speaker 2: Here's the deal. Bill Gates
is very concerned about monkeypox because this is
something apparently he can make a lot of money
off of and him and his other buddies. But in the
blue, blue, blue, blue state of Massachusetts,
someone has contracted monkey pox.
Perhaps they got it from Canada,
from Justin Trudeau's lovely country up there.
Speaker 1: It doesn't appear that the fact that
there's a Canadian nexus has anything
to do with Justin Trudeau's politics.
It seems to have to do with Canadian travelers
to other countries. But do we even care about
the fact when you've got a great story.
Speaker 2: And then even now they're
reporting monkey pox cases in Sweden and Italy?
That is disgusting and it is terrifying. Nasty,
horrible, big bubbles of pus on your skin. I mean,
clearly, nobody wants this. So they're going to
have pictures of all of these kind of terrifying
images. They're going to show children with this
all over their faces. And of course, they're going
to be from I don't know where they're going to be
from. And then they're going to tell you you.
Speaker 1: Have they're going
to be from vile countries.
Speaker 2: Wear a mask from because
if you get close to anyone's face and they spit
on you, you're going to contract this horrible,
terrifying disease. Monkey pox. But don't worry.
You got to go ahead. I know you have a Dr. Fauci
pillow that you sleep with every night. We
need to order your Bill Gates pillow. You
got to have it. You should have a body pillow,
a Bill Gates, and you can cuddle with it every
night because Bill Gates is going to save the day.
Speaker 1: Very, very sick woman. Now, of course,
if it's sexual contact, that is the mechanism for
spread for monkeypox primarily right now. It's
not really clear that some kind of full masking
protocol is really what we need now. It is true
that masks can help prevent the spread of
monkeypox if there are respiratory elements.
But monkeypox doesn't tend to spread via what
we would call small respiratory droplets or
aerosolized respiratory droplets like COVID. Now,
with all of this they stuff, she mentions Bill
Gates, but who is always the they? She mentioned
Massachusetts. So maybe she thinks liberals in
Massachusetts are going to be putting this stuff.
But it's the vague they obviously Bill Gates isn't
the one doing any of this stuff. And then we go
to Alex Jones. Alex Jones insanely claims that
it could be the COVID vaccines that are causing
monkeypox. And watch how he puts this together.
Speaker 3: Monkeypox pops up in more than
20 countries. All over Europe. All over
the US. All over. Everywhere. Where
you have people taking AstraZeneca.
AstraZeneca and J. And J. Ladies and gentlemen.
Mm hmm. Because what is AstraZeneca and JNJ,
right? They're virus vectors that
inject the genome of a chimpanzee.
Into your cells and then orders your
cells to replicate under those orders.
Speaker 1: Okay. So the argument from
Alex Jones here is the JNJ vaccine inserts
a simian, simian means of monkey providence, a
simian genome. And listen, the word monkey is
in monkey pox, after all. So therefore, you know,
published internationalist, Trotskyites socialist.
Yeah. Humans are mostly getting monkey pox from
other humans. So this is a completely harebrained
and completely free of evidence conspiracy theory.
But remember, when the explanation for everything
is somebody who's lied to you, somebody who's
done something to you, a government globalists,
which are disproportionately Jewish men, when
in all of these globalist conspiracy theories,
it's Jewish men. When you have those
scapegoats, of course you're going
to go to them. So we will be following the
monkeypox outbreak from a science perspective,
from a perspective of empiricism and things that
we actually know and can say with certitude. If
you're just listening today and you're morbidly
curious about the clips I played of Marjorie
Taylor GREENE and Alex Jones. You can find them
on our Instagram page at The David Pakman Show.